welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders this is a very special episode
because it's not a traditional a
one-on-one 20-minute interview this is a
panel about the current market situation
how do we get here
how do we traverse through these weird
difficult times whether as an
entrepreneur as an investor how do we
communicate these times to our employees
and to the people in our organizations
and this is a very interesting
conversation
with some incredible thought leaders
from the industry and i hope that you
enjoy
everybody welcome to another awesome
panel and i'm really excited to have you
here talking about today's market and
how the market is vastly different from
what we've known and experienced just a
mere four or five months ago it feels
like the dialogue has changed 180
degrees and then you're all involved
with it with a really really interesting
um report that uh yell benjamin here
is pretty has put together a startup
snapshot and looking at exactly these
questions and so i'm excited to hear
your opinions over the next
half hour 40 minutes or so so thank you
very very much for being here and i'd
love to to get to know you so karine
please take the stage
yeah thanks for having me um i'm karine
schneider i'm the president of ast
private company solutions we provide
software called estrella to help private
companies manage their ownership and
just for background i was a partner at
pwc helping manage compensation design
and ownership programs was ceo of a
number of uh tech companies and was
president of nasdaq private market
before i came to asc
well i'm based in silicon valley
name rod
um nice to meet everyone and it's an
honor to be a part of this um panel or
discussion
um
i'm i've been a corporate lawyer for
over 15 years representing hundreds of
startups from inception through to
wherever they get to and in the last two
years
co-founded with my law firm a consulting
firm for startups and entrepreneurs
called consiglieri
and a digital platform uh with a lot of
content for entrepreneurs called founder
runway and we see a lot of synergies to
uh yale's activities in data sharing
awesome
hi everyone i'm ido i'm the ceo of
american express in israel
uh my background is in uh engineering
and i used to run fintech and
and we had the head of innovation in the
in the third largest bank in israel i've
been mentoring lots of startups uh in
multiple accelerators over the past
eight years or so
and uh i'm excited to be a part of this
channel
thank you for being here
yeah i'll take it away oh yeah yeah
thanks uh thank you so much for inviting
us it was great um the last report that
we launched a couple of months ago we
also had the discussion so it's great to
share our insights this time
so i'll give a bit of background startup
snapshot is an initiative i started
about three years ago and kind of the
whole purpose is to increase
transparency in the tech ecosystem so
there's a lot of data um a lot of a lot
of startups are going through the same
experiences so why not share our data
share our insights and everyone can
benefit um and make much better
decisions going forward and now we
really wanted to see how the whole
workforce market
in the startup ecosystem was really
changing the past couple of months we
collected data from 450 founders and
their employees to kind of see over the
past couple of months how things are
changing
and it was a great great time to really
do this research because the past couple
weeks we're seeing a huge huge shift in
the ecosystem so in april when we asked
founders hiring and employee retention
was the number one challenge for the
majority of founders you know finding
the top talent competing with the big
international organizations the unicorns
in israel um it was really an employee
market they had kind of the upper hand
but when we redid the you know the
survey a couple of weeks later kind of
everything changed so if we're we're
looking really at the end of may
beginning of june um fundraising became
the number one kind of concern for
founders 74 said that they're really
worried about their ability to raise
their next round of funding um a lot of
them are getting calls they're you know
getting active calls from their
investors telling them to cut costs
kind of
work okay you know we're going to go
through a tough
you know no one knows how how long it's
going to be but a tough year or two kind
of work to preserve preserve your costs
and 68 of startups change their hiring
strategy the workforce is a huge you
know um cost component 68 really changed
their hiring strategy they either froze
it or
um really slowed down hiring
so so there's a lot to unpack there
right i think that i have to start with
even
trying to figure out
how the hell do we get to a point where
over a period of weeks
you have a shifting strategy
that is so closely resembling to what
happened in 2008 and and and the dot-com
bubble you know i was here
these months i didn't feel some crazy
crash coming down on me
pushing me to rethink everything i knew
about about the economy and about about
the starts that i'm involved with what
happened here
well i could jump in and just say from a
u.s perspective a couple of things i
mean i think um interest rate changes
have had a massive impact and i think if
you look at 2008
uh you know that with the financial
sector started to impact it and i think
it had just been interest rates um you
know investors are always looking
where's the best place to put my money
where can i make more money so that is
just a fundamental shift for those
people who are perhaps not as risk
interested they're going to say look
interest rates are out maybe there's
other places i want to start putting
money i'm not going to put it in uh you
know in the vc sector or others but i
think you layer on top of that what's
happened in ukraine and and the um and
the inflation issues um and all of a
sudden you've got micro and macro issues
hitting each other at the same time and
i think we didn't have that in 2008 we
really had a banking
sector problem and i think people
thought we would get out of that i think
now um you know and again i compare it
to two years ago with cobid uh way cova
started no one knew how long it would
last but we all just thought well we'll
get through this and fundamentally
things are sound i think the the one
thing i'll say is optimistically and
this is what the press in the u.s is
starting to say is that because of covid
we're actually
financially in much better space so um
regular retail individuals have more
savings
the unemployment rate is so low so from
that perspective there's actually a lot
of optimism there but you layer on all
these pessimism and you've got some
issues
hmm
you do it sounds like you have something
chad
fully agree uh i think compared to 2008
and also covet it's more systemic this
time it's not confined into specific
sector or and the implications are more
broad because it's not just the vcs that
are getting calls from the lps that want
to do something due to the interest
change it's also that inflation is
hurting corporations which are the
potential customers for said um startups
so it's impacting on a much broader
systemic scale that's why we think it
will last longer
um
i wouldn't imagine
uh
countering corrine with her experience
in the nasdaq
um i do believe that there are
differences to 2008 um
in the sense that that one that one sort
of was sourced around the specific
practices um in spaces that are not so
related to high-tech companies
and affected the market uh all the
markets as collateral
um in this specific case
i think tech is going to feel this big
time and i i sort of see a chain of
events that actually begins in covid
so during covid there's an election to
print trillions of dollars of money into
the markets
um and to get it to the needy and the
poor through trickle-down um policies
and when that is the approach when
people aren't paid directly for their
needs but rather the money is uh
trickling down uh top down
what happens is that uh people who get
the money like pension funds or larger
corporations
and use it to incentivize other
companies they will they will have
agency problems they're managing the
money and they might be incentivized to
invest it in high risk
in higher risk
targets and assets such as tech
companies
and then you would see first of all tech
company prices and multiples going up
skyrocketing and then you see money
going into private tech companies by the
way for the israeli market that's huge
because seven trillion dollars even if a
tiny portion of that gets to israel it's
like a tsunami of money
and when agents of money like gps and
investors who are investing other
people's money are investing in tech
companies and there's a lot to gain and
they're competing over a limited supply
of companies of innovation there's
always sort of like the same amount
that's growing steadily they will
overvalue the companies and that's how
you see large tech companies getting
multiples that are irrelevant to
traditional evaluation metrics and
you're seeing private companies just
leveraging fomo sort of investor fear of
missing out to get higher valuations
once
pessimism and realism uh kicks in and
there i totally agree with karine the
war in ukraine
um uh
several botched ipos i think that we
work there's a culprit i think it's one
of those ipos where people are saying
hey do these tech companies know what
they're doing and how they're valuing
themselves
that creates a chain of events that
causes investors to feel like you know
there's a big article about softbank
this morning as well unfortunately and
they're leveraging um
and then that sort of like starts the
domino effect and people start
evaluating the companies again with
their right valuations and now
uh they're just not seeing the money or
not seeing the valuations and investors
are understanding that there are no exit
prospects for their companies so they're
holding on to most of their money to
invest in their existing portfolio and
the market is going to get into a
situation where
they're going to be healthy companies
that raised a lot of money during the
last two years and there are going to be
companies that didn't make it that the
runway is now or in the next few months
and they have to do something and i
think that's a good segue also to your
elves excellent report because that will
create significant shifts in manpower
employees are going to
be moving
around a lot in the next uh in the next
year or two
well i i i agree with with nimrod and
what i would say is i actually go back
i'm old enough to remember 2001 as well
and and so having seen 2001 2008 coven
and now this you know you can you can
draw some parallels and about two years
ago i remember talking to the um the
managing partner with really really
large-scale venture capital firm um and
you know their minimum check size is 50
million and up and he said there's too
much money and we don't know what to do
with this money and so that started
chasing the stock market and i think
that you know that's the other thing is
a the valuations are just not supported
and i think that's what we've had so
we're gonna that you've got the stock
market which we haven't had in previous
cycles although 2001 you could argue the
ipo market was just ridiculous and i
always my antenna goes up when i start
to hear more than three people here and
people are going to take to get a major
reset um you know i will say i live here
in the valley uh you know the the
summers here next three months off so
for these firms who are thinking oh i'm
going to raise
these people work hard the lawyers work
hard the venture capitalists work hard
they're gonna just say look the next
three months i don't need to make
investments i'm gonna just pull back i'm
gonna see what happens we've got midterm
elections coming up i'll see in
september how things are going it's
money in june or july are closed in
august it's not happening you know and
that that's i agree with nimrod the ones
who are on the edge are not going to
make it and that will bring us a very
robust merger and acquisition market
which will bring us out of this that
that's fascinating but but i do have to
go back a little bit and understand
what you know if this is a systemic
change and sort of the writing was on
the wall right i mean that's what i'm
hearing there was no one incident that
crashed it it was an it was a systemic
change maybe the rate of change was
positive so it happened quicker and
quicker like a snowball but still it
almost felt like overnight it became an
a well-known thing where the previous
night everybody was sort of enjoying the
circumstance
is this you know from looking from a
more behavioral perspective or
psychological perspective how do we
explain this both from
founders perspective but also from
investors perspective well i i i had the
privilege of meeting kareem
several months back
i think that people who are
in this industry and he does probably
agree certainly in his position in amex
right
um
that people within the industry within
the core of the industry predicted
pretty much for the quarter if not to
the month
and yeah you're just waiting
for an event
that is public enough that it will
affect also the long tail of humans that
are looking at the market and you're
saying okay that's the event that's now
going to set off the inevitable
chain of events that are going to be the
crash
so not to
you know sort of dismiss your your
know-how of the situation but if you're
in it you know when the market's
crashing you sort of can predict when
it's coming out of it
um and but you still but it'll happen
only when something external and
objective to the general public happens
and i can definitely see that and and
we've seen we've had reports about this
happening and you know thesis building
up over the last year but but i'm pretty
sure that if i look consistently at
almost every firm
especially the really well respected
people that i'm saying wow you know they
are they're really at the core of it
they kept making investments at you know
35 million pre-money seed rounds because
even though they may know that it's not
reasonable so how do we explain that
because because the nature of markets
are not fully reasonable right so people
were here for 2008 and i don't have any
hair but if i were they were great
and 2001
the same markets are cyclical right so
we understand it's coming
no one can pinpoint the exact date so
there was a feeling for the past a year
and a half that the markets are and the
valuations are too big right but no one
knows the exact date right so there's a
pressure to continue investing because
you don't know if it's in a week's time
two months time or two years time right
and you and you feel that you're missing
investments you need and you have your
lp's that are pushing you to leverage
the funds that you're getting it just
keeps on going that's why when there's
an event
that is like the check box for that what
everyone within the industry were
feeling that's about to happen they know
this is the moment right that's why the
response is extremely quick as well yeah
and the playbook's been written
that's the thing we we know from covid
you know you gotta move quick so i think
people pulled out a lot of stuff from
there and just said okay we're gonna do
this again and i think if you if you
read the messages carefully the messages
are let's be careful let's be prudent
they're not saying you know this is the
end of everything it's just you know
let's smart
right
yeah
manage the runway that's the
definitely and i want to bring in
another point over here i think you know
i don't know how dramatic this is going
to be i don't know you know i don't want
to go to a negative place but i think
that in today's market the rules of the
games kind of have changed and startups
what we saw is that a very large percent
of startups um in the past couple weeks
said that their focus was on securing
sales much faster so i think you know
startups kind of and it's a very healthy
place to get to steps have to show a
business model prop not profitability
but some form of revenue market
validation client validation much faster
on in the process and i think that is
some kind of a healthy correction to the
market to where it was you know a couple
of months ago
great
fully agree i think i think founders now
need to change their focus they were
focused in the past year and a half on
growth that means that they
thought about hiring as their first
priority building features growing the
customer base now they understand they
need to manage the runway and also so
showed some sort of of a way going
forward of having a cash flow positive
business down the line
so the internal focus goes from hiring
towards
your sales team your your marketing
funnels and understanding which features
you need to bring in to be able to
leverage new customers into the
endodontics
definitely i i also think um you know
kind of clean we spoke about that a lot
of um what kind of opportunities are
coming out of here could write down in
covid kind of startups that moved fast
and were able to leverage new
opportunities that were forming were the
ones that came out of let's call it this
crisis much stronger so the research
found that a large percent of startups
think that there's an opportunity to
snatch up top talent from the public you
know the public companies
the stocks really they went down a lot
of these employees the time until you
know their stocks come back up to what
they were before could be a couple of
years
so the risk level that they're willing
to take you know it's becoming much
similar to startup in the end
so there's the opportunity really for
startups for early-stage startups that
weren't able to compete and weren't
attractive to this top talent before to
kind of um get those get those to go
those guys now
karen and we also spoke a lot about the
m a market
yeah a little venture original point
there there's some
there's some really good um articles out
there that said you know show what
companies came out of 2001 2008 2015 and
like uber you know is a good example
these were all smart people who were
working for bigger companies who
you know look at this and as you said
okay i'm not going to make the kind of
return on my public company stock that i
thought in the next two to three years
so what am i going to do with that time
and that's i think where people are
looking at what's the best return on my
time
and so you're going to see coming out of
2022 you're going to see some amazing
companies that got get founded and six
seven years from now we're going to be
talking about them because these are
folks who are saying i don't want to
work for google or facebook or you know
wherever because i'm going to go
somewhere else so it is interesting how
people will look at it that way up i do
think that we've talked about the m a
market and i think the aqua higher mark
um
at least it incept everybody's
employees so it's a good time to kind of
say look i'm going to get rid of the top
but that's hot but i don't get rid of
five or ten percent people who i wasn't
crazy anyway uh and i'm just you know
i'm gonna kind of scale back a little
bit and so those people aren't moderate
but i also think these small startups
are going to be looking for people to
buy them and and larger companies with
cash um or equity that's where something
are going to have a great buying
opportunity
um yeah i mean if
i i i'm i fully agree with karine um
i think that
a startup
is a lot like
uh schredinger's cat
it's dead and alive at the same time
uh
so
when it's when it's dead it's like it's
fully dead and i'll explain it in a bit
and when it's alive it's it's very much
alive so the ones that that raised money
there they're alive
the ones that didn't raise money and the
runways in the upcoming six to ten
months and their investors are not
going to follow on for any reason
because their investors also have to
look at their portfolio and decide who
they're going to save in a sense
so the ones that aren't going to be
saved
even if they're still
under the hat they're dead
and that means that
they're going to be up for sale
for
pretty much their debt
and if they can get burnout
uh post-merger um or some retention then
they'll have a good story to tell and
they'll be in a sense
they'll still have a chance for some
legacy
so what this does for companies that did
raise 20 million and up 15 million and
up is it gives them an opportunity to
buy companies startup companies
for their outstanding pretty much
working capital
uh when it's left for hundreds of
thousands of dollars or for a few
millions of dollars or
um
if they really want the tech and not
only the people maybe they need to repay
the investors their principal back so
that could be 10 15 million but still
there's an opportunity for
small m a's
and if you structure them right
then these companies can come out really
strong from uh
from from the next year or two
and when i mean structure them right
that's not a that's not a small thing
the other the good the the one thing
that does
normally
describe these uh
big startups the ones that did raise a
lot of money is that they're still young
companies they're not serial acquirers
um so it's not so simple
to to do an equihire when most mergers
fail and most integra post mergers
integration fail that requires a lot of
skills that very few tech companies in
the world actually have in a phone
successfully
moreover
these startup companies that might
acquire other companies for employees
for talent
let's say facebook acquires a company
facebook isn't raising money again from
venture capital funds and isn't ipoing
again facebook is public
um so they just need the merger to sort
of succeed or not succeed and that might
affect the trend of the share price and
that's it and they're offering to the
public but if i'm a post b post c
company and i'm and i'm buying another
company i'm still going to raise money
from vcs and undergo due diligence
and i'm still going to try and go public
i need to know the company that i'm
buying
inside out
what that means is
that a lot of deals the a lot of these
deals are going to be asset deals where
the buyers are buying the assets of the
sellers which creates bad tax
consequences for the sellers but are
simpler deals for the buyers
these deals are really interesting
because you're essentially firing the
employees from the seller hiring them at
the buyer integrating them it it's a
really interesting structure and you
need to go through all the motions of an
m a hr due diligence business due
diligence
legal due diligence and really know the
target really well you can't take
gambles so it's going to be an
interesting period they're going to be
many of them but they're going to be
also many stories to learn from in the
next year uh after some companies pursue
these acquisitions
wow
and so if if we're looking at the
landscape of founders is there do you
feel that there's a
a common understanding that the that
there are these various opportunities
that that founders of series b series
companies especially first-timers can
now
actually reason through i imagine quite
a few of my friends that are in series
being seriously companies i don't know
if they would wake up tomorrow and say
wow i can actually go and acquire assets
from a competitor that until three days
ago we were in raising we were in the
same you know sort of similar boats
i think it's even deeper than that i
don't think all founders understand that
that's
like an even a possibility going forward
right i think we'll have we'll
experience a few months now
where
most founders are actually scrambling to
understand how they're dealing with this
crisis they understand they need to
understand their situation
what the vc is
asking them to do and then they'll
they'll look at their options right so
some of them will understand that they
don't have a runway
and will start reaching out and and the
other side of the equation those that
will take the next two to three months
and lay over some people but understand
that they have the ability to to weather
the storm
then they'll look at the opportunities
but i think it will take a few months at
least before things start to fully sink
in
and and plants start playing being laid
out
uh i just add to what he does said that
um
i love the agency problem i love where
like i said before you know where
investors are investing other people's
money they might overvalue a target to
get the deal it's not malicious or
nefarious it's not to make more money
it's just the way that people work when
they're not making a decision on their
own capital
same goes for a cfo of a startup that
raised
um that raised 30 or 40 million
sure the company as a whole may not know
what it's going to do a cfo might think
this is going to be a cool experience
for me to buy some companies if i can
get them or an h or a chief people
officer might think that and they might
be champions of an acquisition
they might become that because there's
an opportunity for them it's still a
human thing right the company itself is
an imaginary entity it's like us
together doing something and
incorporated
though
i think that yeah most people he does
absolutely right they've got the fear of
understanding what their investors want
but somewhere if the company raised 30
million they hired an excellent cfo
executive with experience that cfo wants
to do something that you know that
enables them to look at themselves in
the mirror that's buying other companies
and i think korean you bought like a
bunch of companies and you like doing
that that's something your experience
with that's something that drives you
that you want to do more of it
obviously reasonably and rationally but
it's it's a thing that it's a it's a
good thing to deal with it's fun
yeah i would say too and i i was uh you
know when i saw the zendesk feel i think
on friday um you know private equity is
is where in 2008 private equity kind of
stayed in its lane and venture capital
stayed in its lane i think we're
starting to see that also merge so
you're starting to see a whole other
different way of looking at these
acquisitions and i think private equity
now is circling some of these way you
know traditionally they wouldn't have
looked at that company but now they're
starting to say who in my portfolio
could benefit from
kind of a wounded animal on the side of
the road you know you're running out of
money you've got some good people you've
got some good tack maybe you've got some
good clients i could pick you up for a
song and then you know merge you into
one of my portfolio companies that could
benefit from this and that to me is
going to be a massive cultural clash
because you're going to start to see
these traditional venture-backed
companies with their culture and their
way of doing things and innovation
merging with companies that are maybe
more traditional older been around a
long time that weren't well operated and
now you're going to try to shut those
together and i think that's going to be
another interesting you know if i put my
business school hat on and said you know
looking for another case study that's
going to be for me another case study
from this
time so i'm wondering
if we're looking from a from a founder
perspective
if we're now in a position where we're
saying okay so we have we have the
runway and we you know we have maybe an
opportunity to put our heads down and
for the next 12 months not even think
about the market just build the product
is that is that a reasonable sort of
strategy for a founder and upset because
to me it sounds like a pretty amazing
opportunity to say okay i'm detaching
myself a little bit now from from the
market and i'm going to spend a lot of
time with my team really building out an
amazing product
it's i think it will happen i started a
company
well i was just going to say i started i
launched a company in 2001. i launched a
company in 2008
um and i launched a company in 2000 or a
product in 2020 so i like to think i'm
really good at at finding the right
timing for this um in every case i think
i think you kind of have to do both
unfortunately michael and this is what
happens with startups yeah if you've got
the money and you've got the talent i
think heads down spend the next 12
months and grow and build and develop
but i think the ceos of these companies
need to be spending 25 percent of their
time looking at what's out there like
mimeron said you know you've got to be
looking for the opportunities for either
tech or people
or client acquisition you've got to be
doing partnerships uh you've got to be
looking at kind of a larger you know
what what do i do after 12 months and if
you think that you're the ceo and you
don't have to worry about it for 12
months i think you're gonna wake up at
12 months and and either have lost some
great opportunities or um you're going
to be in a lot of trouble i i think you
just cannot avoid what's going on here
there's going to be some seismic shifts
and you're going to have to make sure
that your company is part of that sizing
shift
you know do you want to enter into that
exactly i think i
fully agree with korean what what i'd
like to add is the fact that i think the
situation is even more complex for
founders now right so you know the past
year they they focused primarily on
raising funds now they also need to look
at partnerships as you've said also need
to maintain the connection with
potential uh
fundraising for the next round
they also need to understand the market
there are less players in the market so
they're they've got to reach out to uh
to potential customers and leverage that
opportunity
and they also need to manage their
talent because
if their current valuation and the
feeling in the market is all that all
valuations are down their top talent
understands that they have a potential
to go to a new startup
and enjoy the hockey stick there so they
need to fully communicate what they are
feeling from the vcs that they are
communicating with about their current
valuation to their top talent and
explaining to them that their stock
options are worth something and the
company is on a good trajectory
and because they have so much on their
plate uh sometimes some of those pieces
fall between the cracks and i think the
situation is much more complex than it
used to be interesting so it sounds like
over communication
a positive trend
definitely i i want to add to from what
he just said about the communication i
think that's that's
you know a key that kind of founders
have to focus on in the next couple of
months is kind of how how do i tell the
story to my employees in order to really
get them on board and and really get
them focused in the direction that you
know we're moving the ship in a new
direction now how do we get everyone
focused in that direction and we see the
report that there's you know a huge
asymmetry of information between
founders and their employees so the
founders we've seen the past couple
weeks are really understanding that
there's a huge shift in the market
they're worried they're kind of adapting
to the new reality but employees are
still living in the market of 2021. uh
68 said that they're not even worried
you know about their future in the
company and what's happening going
forward
so
you know we're seeing that asymmetry of
information that employees aren't part
of the conversation you know behind
closed doors with investors with clients
um they know about how they're doing
company but they don't know about how
the company is doing as a whole and kind
of how the economic shifts are going to
affect valuations going forward so i
think in a couple of weeks you know
things are really going to start to to
sink in for them and it's going to be
really up to the founders to how do you
communicate this to get everyone on
board okay
and that's part of the
part of the responsibility of the boards
because uh it comes with experience that
you need in these times of distress to
communicate even more than you used to
communicate in the past even if you feel
that you don't have anything to
communicate so
updating your top talent on meeting a vc
and understanding that the valuation is
eighty percent of what you you
experience but the mark that the feeling
in the media is that valuation were cut
in half is a good thing to communicate
to your top talent but you need to be a
really experienced leader to understand
and to put yourself in that position and
i think the boards will have to step in
and will have to to uh
mentor their uh their founders and and
going through this absolutely
and i just you know we
michael you asked earlier
what is the behavioral shift like what
triggers
the uh you know the crisis or the or the
downtick
also within a company in its culture
it's going to be one small event
that sends the employees into a frenzy
and i just want to give an example of
that event and i think
i think both korean and idol will really
connect with this specifically the share
management platform that green has
um
let's say you're looking at the cohort
of employees in your company
to whom you granted option in the last
two years
at at least the us employees and in most
israeli companies also the israeli
employees they're gonna get those
options at an exercise price reflecting
the fair market value of the or of the
shares
at a certain exercise price if they were
granted in the last two years that
exercise price is high
one of these people one takes one is
gonna leave
in the next few
um
let's say months
and they're going to realize when they
need to pony up the money for the
exercise price that their options are
out of the money because they're going
to understand they're going to collect
some information some of it in israeli
companies it's publicly available you
know what the last price of the last
preferred share was in the articles of
association but if they piece it
together they might find out that their
options are out of the money even in a
private company and when they find out
they're going to be in dismay and
they're going to tell their friends and
that sort of cooler talk
around that
that could create um a real uh forest
fire within your company so i think when
he does says control the narrative and
be an experienced leader it's also
dividing your employees into cohorts and
seeing who are the employees that i
brought in
when the story was that i was telling
was so big
that it currently doesn't fit how the
markets look at my company because that
story wasn't only an intangible uh you
know kumbaya sort of thing it was also
it has tangible aspects like within the
exercise price of the options
and if you look at that you know you
look at wework
when you look at like a dramatization of
it like we crashed all the employees are
pissed off but if you listen to adam
newman uh in an interview around this
matter he's gonna say no you're missing
the point here's where i missed i missed
on the employees that i hired prior to
the ipo and gave them a really high
exercise price
those people got screwed and understood
that without the ipo their options are
out of the money those people leaked the
all the bad things into the press and
that sort of gave a very that shed a
very bad light on the entire company
otherwise the the early employees still
made hundreds of millions tens of
millions or even billions of dollars in
the small ideals that the company did
you don't control the narrative you
don't communicate that's how your
company's gonna get hurt in this process
incredible uh it sounds like while the
information may be there it's accessible
you can know it today
part of the behavioral shift is gonna
cause some seismic waves that will take
some some maybe singular multiple events
to send ricochets down with information
that the founders and and strong leaders
can in effect make use of today and and
make their lives better their employees
lives better and and control a little
bit of of the dramatic narrative that
that everybody's feeling especially it's
like you're saying
your company's stance is even a little
bit better than what may be perceived by
the outside world that that over that
communication obviously is helpful and i
really want to thank all of you for
coming this was so enjoyable for me you
know i i get to dive into
a technology in my day-to-day mainly
look at software and look at trends
within the academic papers and finally i
get to sit outside and to understand how
this is impacting the larger market
the cyclical effects of it the
predictableness of it
but also the the understanding that yes
we may have to we will continue to
participate in the cyclical nature
because this is a part of the job and we
can we don't have the crystal ball when
it's happening and so those were some
really some really monumental moments
for me as well as talking about talent
and over communication and everything in
between so thank you very very much for
all your time and i can't share this
with everybody thank you
[Music]